[Music]
chris was tremendously excited about
those lows wasn't it he got very
enthusiastic
summer is the season of road trips and
we're packing up the car heading out to
show you a few places you want to check
out in the new series it's called vegas
drives first up need a quick getaway
with the family that is less than two
hours away las vegas now's jc fernandes
has an idea for you who's ready for a
road trip today we're going 90 miles
south of town to laughlin nevada for
what this is something very special for
the entire family come on
it's an easy drive just head towards
boulder city take the 95 south to the
163 east and if you get hungry you can
stop in searchlight stop here at gus's
jerky it's delicious
[Music]
welcome to laughlin nevada where you can
do gambling you can go to the spa you
can go golfing there's water activities
but today we're here for something very
special don laughlin's plastic car
museum and this is brian he runs the
place good to see you buddy nice to meet
you
[Music]
brian i got to tell you it's great to be
here it took me 90 minutes to get down
here i'm a car lover so this is extra
special for me how many cars do you have
in the museum over 50 over 50. let's
take a look because what i love about
driving to laughlin it's an easy day
trip where do you guys get all these
cars from they're from people that just
want to put them on display
other people want to consign them and we
sell them
um i like the super the super b you have
right here and the color too it's plum
crazy the color jumps out to you what
you guys are open seven days a week open
to all ages this is open seven days a
week all ages what i like to about is
air conditioning inside here yes
nice and comfy how many people do you
have coming down from las vegas to visit
it depends what's going on down here i
mean we can have
20 people here we can have a hundred
people through a day while visiting be
sure and say hi to bud one of the
museum's curators i told you i'd bring
it last year yeah sure have one so i
wanted to bring it to you oh thank you
very much thank you very
seemed very special what just happened
uh a customer brought in their pets to
put on a void for the police for the
quality
and i'm proud to do this for everybody
and you can see look at this this is
from all across the country firefighters
and policemen they send you their their
packages yes sir well why don't you go
ahead and put it on the wall so it's
more than just cars here at the classic
car museum
what a special moment
don laughlin's classic car museum is
sure to bring back great memories and
certainly create new ones